okay we are back with Victoria Beckham
your name is synonymous with
empowerment and fashion and Beauty but
also a woman that we respect and admire
and thank you I on a personal level I
had had both my daughters Olive and
Frankie Frankie was just a baby she was
like four months old and Olive was I
turning two
she had her second birthday and I knew
that um you know because both of us were
in different professions at a certain
point and
I think we are not all one thing I think
we are many different things and if we
have the opportunity to explore one of
those other avenues after
um being in another one that was working
really well but you want to Pivot and
switch gears I knew that I wanted to
take a break from acting I felt like my
kids needed me and then I needed to be
there for them like I didn't want to
play a character I needed to be my kid's
mom that was the role of my life
and I I went to London and it was the
last film I made for many years actually
actually it was the last film I made
um and one day my daughter went to a
park
and you know we did we didn't know
anybody there and she made a friend and
I was so excited that she made a friend
I was like oh thank God you know you
made a friend here this is wonderful
news it turned out to be your daughter
Harper
I do
but
I I mean I have to I have to say that
Harper's always loved playing with your
girls because they're such adorable
little girls and and Harper has really
enjoyed getting to know your guts and I
have never in my life met children who
are as well behaved kind generous
humorous full of humanity the most
incredible kids what's a good parenting
advice because you have raised such kind
generous kids thank you that that's very
kind of you to say that and you know
it's the greatest compliment because I
love what I do professionally but for me
being a good mom is the most important
job for me I always say to Harper it
doesn't matter who is the cleverest girl
at school it doesn't matter who is the
prettiest girl at school what matters is
who is the kindest and sweetest girl
in the classroom and that's the most
important I got to come over to your
house
um your husband the David Beckham
he he made lovies for Olive and Frankie
with Harper with their names on them and
he supports your beauty line in fact we
have a little something do you mind
playing the clip I hope Victoria's
behaving herself my one Beauty question
to Victoria would be
do I have this on right I mean it
doesn't stick to my beard as well as it
sticks to Victoria's but
I love that
I've met him and he seems like the
nicest man in the world to be like he's
you know he's he's amazing he's so
supportive we're both supportive of each
other
um and that's why I got so emotional at
the show in Paris because I planned on
coming out after the show and I wanted
you know a great picture walking down
the catwalk and the minute I saw David
and the kids and my mom and my dad and
my sister I just got so emotional I
really did because family are everything
to me and have them there to support me
is just everything but in answer to your
question he's he's a really really
really great dad he's a fantastic
husband he works so so hard and I feel
very lucky that we have each other okay
so how is Harper she's great she's
really really great actually she's just
started a new school and she's so
sociable and she loves it and she works
hard and she's just so happy and I think
the main thing that we want from our
kids we want them to be happy right
that's what we want so she totals off to
school every day she's got lovely
friends does she um is it true I was
reading somewhere that she comments on
your previous outfits from the past is
that true oh yeah I mean she saw some
pictures of me when I was in the Spice
Girls and she said Mommy your skirts
were way too short
way too short
I know I know but uh yeah she does quite
often look at the costumes you know and
the skin type catsuits and the mini
skirts and the high heels yeah it's so
funny when the 90s fashion is so back
too is there anything that you still
love from the 90s or anything you're
like oh that does not need to come back
you know I think that the 90s always
influence fashion because it really was
such an incredible time for fashion but
what I'm hoping does not come back are
those big Spice Girl shoes that they
used to wear you know I mean I didn't
wear them in the 90s the other girls did
um but I'm we're always rocking a sexy
heel always rocking a heel but the girls
used to love these big big shoes so I'm
hopeful that that they don't come back I
do think your fashion is extremely
Timeless thank you I do believe that
when you put on your clothes when you
wear your makeup a woman does feel her
best and if that is your mission I
believe it is accomplished thank you
thank you thank you so much thank you
you know
you know it used to be about empowering
young girls and boys in music that was
what girl power was
um and now it's just about empowering
women through both fashion and Beauty I
want to make women and and Men you know
feel like the best version of themselves
that's my goal I feel like you were so
ahead of your time also because your
fashion is not overly girly there was
something that actually made a woman
feel very powerful and a lot of your
Silhouettes have been extremely neutral
you're not like lacy frilly like you're
you had a crystal ball of how to appeal
to everyone
um and I just I'm in awe of you I'm so
excited to have this conversation for
you to honor Us by coming on the show
and what means most to you if the
mission is accomplished of you
empowering people and entertaining us
and being an icon and a beacon of so
many wonderful things throughout your
career if Mom is the most important that
is the mission accomplished of all
because boy are your kids
thank you so much you too thank you and
it is my number one too all else is so
second
Victoria Beckham thank you for coming
here today it is such a blessing to talk
to you and I'm so glad our little girls
found each other at a time when our
family really needed
um connection well thank you so much
we've got to get them together again
we have to Victoria Beckham Beauty line
is available
beauty.com we'll be right back
[Music]